[Music]
in heartless in a hurry news submitted
by sending love to Tiff's Gio but not
David Oh awesome you're the freakin best
but lucky that's crazy how losers stick
together let's continue
yeah I agree that person is definitely a
freakin loser didn't choose on it
because he's a down-ass homie that's
right not Steve hey you know what you
know how much control we have over your
[ __ ] life
we just thought Nikki one thing about
you that's bad get her thinking and your
[ __ ] over you [ __ ] she's right
no loyalty that's [ __ ] up baby thing
I'm a man suffering a man suffering a
seizure was dragged off a train by a
passenger interrupt I saw no I was you
just reminded about the Epilepsy karate
class thing I have I just laughing about
that [ __ ] last night dude cuz it's
pretty crazy to think of a guy doing
forms when the fall asleep okay you know
you remember the boondocks yeah do you
remember uncle ruckus he looks like
uncle ruckus yeah yeah he looks like
uncle ruckus where his eyes are like one
side and the other side
he's like really
imagine just some regular looking dude
oh dude just forms and falls asleep but
a guy who looks like there's an issue
it's a little less fun you guys
you gotta see what uncle ruckus looks
like it's it's it's it's a it's funny
because this guy looks like threatening
like he looks he looks like he could
[ __ ] some [ __ ] up like imagine a tough
dude my name is uncle rob and i will be
[ __ ] leading you to until your
grandfather over time okay I get it
yeah but the eye is yeah everybody has
the eyes
go all over the place okay all right
good to know you can't run away from him
yeah she looks like a mean dude that
could [ __ ] some [ __ ] up and then he just
falls asleep in the middle of class
we're doing karate all right so this
story here she did yeah it was last week
no no this last one I meant to say this
last J can you shoot the southern belle
speaks all right so this takes please I
like it - I like it - looks good yeah
something bells pretty you see
unconscious at all what are you guys
talking about what the [ __ ] dude you're
not hideous I keep telling you're not
[ __ ] ugly got people like you got we
want you here do you think I am that if
I'm not ugly what am i you just tell
ugly what is it I got identified with
something what am i what am i you're
like you're my wife yes yes just just
say you're decent oh you're a decent
human being it's like Hollywood in
Highland the characters who stand in for
a Hollywood Highland you're Wonder Woman
out there and then you're like hey we
work for tips okay we work for tips
yeah no free pictures yeah thank you I
got you would you be down to do that
dress up is one norm and go out there
and see if there's another Wonder Woman
that has already claimed that territory
now you guys got to fight it out why do
I have to fight one another because you
actually kind of do look like gal gadot
you I bet you a bring in hella glop like
you just [ __ ] raking money you could
have a Vegas show by yourself like a
Vegas impersonator Wonder Woman show I'd
be good no but then there's a jackass
like Steve sitting all the way in the
fries gonna be like is is not really
grand in like four hours watch dude I
did a spider-man video there [ __ ] I
went to the Michael Jackson show that
[ __ ] front row and I believed that
[ __ ] so just went into his body
and then [ __ ] Michael Jackson was
singing to me it was him use him
as a vessel even though gal gadot is not
dead yet her spirit when she goes to
sleep enters your soul and does a Wonder
Woman perform you should do Wonder Woman
at Hollywood huh now be tired actually
okay don't do what I went there one time
with 40 Spider Man
so I cornered the entire market on
spider-man there because there's always
like - Spider Man they're always pissed
off that each other exists so then I
went there as spider-man and then I got
like 40 people off of Craigslist
and they I am we got him all Spider Man
costumes and so we were I flooded the
whole [ __ ] thing was amazing video
and they were so [ __ ] by awesome oh
it was so fun and then I and then I took
a little further like so I went I went
into bumble bee like because there's a
big bumblebee guy there oh yeah and I
started like filling the pictures all of
his pictures with spider-man boss and I
was filling everyone's [ __ ] was
spider-man they were eating so I was
getting all the carnies all pissed off
yeah it was probably your most
successful but video but the one you
lost the most money honestly views my
eyes I didn't do as well for summary I
don't know why but it was [ __ ] one of
my funnier ones I sounds amazing
a couple hundred bucks yeah a couple
hundred that's it
well spider-man costumes happen to be
pretty cheap Oh which is why a lot of
people go away ten bucks each that's
$400 they're like 30 bucks each other it
was a lot of money what about people
hundred bucks you bastard anymore I'm
like dude my [ __ ] costs so much [ __ ]
money of no idea the [ __ ] video was
like [ __ ] easy after all that [ __ ]
public to grand bro easily this story
here it takes place in Long Beach this
man had a seizure he looks like he came
straight out of the hospital because he
had staples in his head and he still had
him a medical man damn I pictured this
dude in like a [ __ ] gown and
everything just in the middle of the
Train no yeah - sure did sweat oh thank
god
and so he had a seizure but this other
dude a man in a suit didn't want to wait
for the paramedics or anything he just
wanted to keep the train moving so he
dragged the man
outside so here is the video and there's
some background music no it's like a see
if you try to make a [ __ ] I took the
train so here you go about [ __ ]
business
you ain't giving a [ __ ] I'm gonna fun
being rude you took about the train car
you didn't give a funny you just want to
go to the [ __ ] now it don't matter
what the [ __ ] you Dawson he had a
[ __ ] seizure okay now say you have no
right to put hands over see you had no
[ __ ] right to put your hands on why
did he go back out because the Train
wasn't moving like the Train wasn't he's
like well I might as well care of one of
the guys we're not
it's ass out to a lot like yeah the guy
that was filming it's like a six minute
video of him just talking [ __ ] to that
white guy I love the [ __ ] commentary
dude wow that's crazy that Method Man
recorded that [ __ ] dude I was like a
wild it sounded just like him house
[ __ ] crazy so the train stopped to
wait for the paramedics to come I see I
didn't see any other people in that car
except for him and that guy and
definitely didn't see no paramedics yeah
we all also left him as well holy [ __ ]
so all I saw was just dick in the very
beginning he dragged him out and when he
dragged him out they didn't like undo
his path that's so sad yeah and then so
he before he moved him he was asking
people to help him drag him out of it
why didn't he just leave him there and
wait until the paramedics came you want
to wait he was like I want to go home
yeah he wanted to get the problem out so
that the problem gets solved out and
then the train leaves is he the guy's a
problem but that's like treating people
like livestock you're not supposed to
move people would think right no no
that's what I already thought is like
why is he moving him in the first place
it's very interesting because maybe he's
just I'm not like defending the guy but
I think he's like one of those like
socially inept human beings where he has
no of [ __ ] emotions like for him is
just logic he goes to he's solving two
problems at once he goes we all get to
go home and this guy gets to get his
care I get to go but he took the human
equation out of it so the guys even
thought he was doing the guys filming a
favor no because why would he go back
outside
maybe after he called them out enough
he's like oh [ __ ] I am NOT being a human
right now yeah and then he started to it
seemed like he was like pretending to
care of yeah I did yeah well yeah he got
guilted into right because because he
was being recorded and people were poppy
talking [ __ ] because no one's clapping
for that [ __ ] like that's that's almost
like if an accident happens or whatever
you know unless the cars burning you
don't touch the [ __ ] person to get
out of there yeah but what this guy did
is like
I gotta go to work bro and he pulled out
all the people from that car crash and
he says move over so I could drive
that's exactly Yeah right
man I'm not going anywhere he's like oh
[ __ ] this is probably going viral he's
like well I'm still in the video I
probably clean this up I didn't know
about the whole thing
like not touching somebody you know cuz
you could get sued too because in
Sacramento there's like there's this
huge accident that happened and all I
saw was it wasn't just me it was me and
a couple of other people all we saw was
[ __ ] car smoking two cars smashed
together and this guy was stuck knocked
out all we thought was that cars gonna
[ __ ] explode
so we you know opened it up oh yeah
that's when you you know if there if you
think their life is threatened don't
move them but you don't want to because
if they have like some type of injury
what happens is they could be paralyzed
if you snap something or whatever yeah
and well for seizures - like what you're
supposed to do is try to lean them up
like if you if you see someone going
through yeah cuz they'll choke all their
own [ __ ] vomit or whatever yeah and in
the way that he left them is he pulled
him out and then he was faced out he was
faced up which that's some dangerous ass
[ __ ] I don't know I don't think that
that guy cared about anything it was
just more like get the [ __ ] out of my
way and I was just complete selfishness
I did something so my brother when he
was in UC San Diego I used to go visit
him frequently cuz I was in Riverside
Riverside suck but then it was for his
birthday he got [ __ ] like pissed off
like [ __ ] smashed I could hear him
throw up but I was so drunk and tired I
just literally moved his face over this
way so you wouldn't joke on his own
vomit that's when he woke up with vomit
all over
I cared enough where I pushed his face
over intense love though damn that's
homie lover because people could died on
that [ __ ] yeah it's funny how we treat
people who are like going through a
seizure we're like oh [ __ ] everybody get
back everyone through Chell but if a
guy's like drunk is [ __ ] like this guy
apparently thought that this guy was
drunk you're just like how [ __ ] drunk
I [ __ ] you like I I definitely have done
that I've felt that way yeah like seeing
drunk people I'm always like fun I don't
even want to touch people
they're probably stinking [ __ ] [ __ ] that
you are that guy oh yeah I just wait for
the paramedics to touch I'm a rubber
gloves and [ __ ]
[Music]